hey youtubers is Charlie so this is
gonna be my episode 3 and for review
from daredevil also includes some stuff
from episode 1 and 2 that are a little
spoiler II that I that I kept out of my
non-spoilery review just open it up I
know I know a lot of your asking
questions about where daredevil falls in
the timeline of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and like like where's the
Avengers tower and just a couple small
things like that
daredevil comes after a Winter Soldier
so shield has fallen people are still
rebuilding after the Battle of Manhattan
because they keep referring to the event
but since we don't see the Avengers
Tower in the skyline we can just presume
that they haven't finished building it
yet so this is before age of Ultron they
do make light references to heroes in
their consequences so that's like a
subtle wink at the Avengers themselves
and I think depending on some of the
other cast that they bring into Captain
America Civil War
we could see some daredevil references
even if he doesn't have a starring role
we could hear about the devil of Hell's
Kitchen the Netflix series will be
relatively self-contained so just expect
the same treatment in terms of crossover
with characters just like a little bit
more once we see the other Netflix
characters but that's about it
now that Marvel has access to spider-man
in a small way we also might see some
integration of spider-man related stuff
like The Daily Bugle for instance just
careful for spoilers from the episodes
if you haven't seen him yet so so what
I'm gonna do because this is a little
bit different in the way they they
posted the episodes is I'm mostly gonna
focus on like that character beets
episode 3 is rabbit in a snowstorm
referring to kingpins painting here
episode 4 is in the blood
most of these episodes are dedicated to
introducing the other characters we even
get like a villain flashback so as much
as we get hero flashbacks for Matt
Murdock we get flashbacks for the
kingpin and the Russians the most
exciting characters at least you know
beyond the kingpin I think that we meet
in these episodes are Claire temple we
get a deeper dive into her I mean we met
her in episode 2 in Vanessa 2 relatively
minor characters in the comics but ones
that I think that the TV show that the
Netflix series is gonna make much more
use of episode 3 is mostly about the
defense of the bowling alley killer the
creepily calm bowling alley killer if
you're a little confused as to why
kingpin wanted to hire them for this he
bit he basically wanted to like slowly
rein them in a little bit bring them on
the kingpin team so to speak it just
made the whole trial seem more legit we
get to see Matt Murdock in a courtroom
scene for the first time this
a lot of fun I expect to see more of
this in season 2 whenever that comes he
solves as many problems in the courtroom
as he does with punching and kicking
it's also a reminder that he's a badass
attorney like he's really smart so on
the other side of the coin
Karen Paige and Ben Urich start their
investigations into kingpins company
whenever they met and Ben Urich said
that he looked into Karen's past and
found some really fishy stuff that's a
reference to stuff from the born-again
storyline that's a comic book that Frank
Miller wrote so if we get the season 2
we might hear about that stuff but it
isn't a reference to anything that
happened in season 1 of daredevil so the
shady stuff she was involved in had
nothing to do with what's going on with
a kingpin right now I am a big fan of
this version of Karen page that the
daredevil TV series version is you know
she's not a hooker with a heart of gold
like most of Frank Miller's women and
she solves most of her problems the
showrunner Steven denied actually
clarified that this isn't like a
straight-up adaptation of a Frank Miller
comic he said they just took a lot of
visual elements as well as characters
and kind of made them their own it's
kind of the same deal with the movies
with the Marvel Cinematic Universe
changing characters just a little bit
episode 4 though also brings us to like
this big Claire temple Matt Murdock
storyline the Russians capture Claire
Matt Murdock goes after them this is
like the beginning of the end for the
Russians pretty much I really liked his
rescue scene where he basically takes
all the Russians out and then when he's
giving his big hero monologue to like
that final villain Claire temple just
whacks him with the baseball bat that's
another good example of a twist on a
Frank Miller character Claire temple is
from the comics you can think of her as
the the night nurse character from the
comics she's just like a nurse who
treats the street-level heroes whenever
they get the kicked out of him so
she has high crossover potential for
like Luke Cage iron fist Jessica Jones
they'll be running around getting their
butts kicked in their own episode so
they'll need someone to patch them up
eventually most of the events on
daredevil are self-contained to Hell's
Kitchen it sounds like a relatively
small area but it's like it's right here
in Manhattan after the 80s whenever
Giuliani cleaned up New York they
renamed Hell's Kitchen to Midtown West
to make it sound nicer the Avengers
tower just as a point of reference is
over here in the middle of Midtown so at
some point in these Netflix series we'll
probably see an Avengers Tower at least
by defenders I think Ben and Karen's
stories like start to come together a
little bit more he starts to come on
board you know initially he's very
locked in but then he's like oh you know
I came here to investigate this auction
- I wasn't here to find you
I like the fax machine joke that they
paid off foggy goes on and on about this
story that apparently he tells to Matt
every time he gets pissed off and it
seems like they might be tying like the
foggy and Karen characters together in
the comics both Matt Murdock and foggy
Nelson had like this love triangle going
on with Karen page at various points I'm
kind of glad they don't lean on it too
hard because it doesn't really fit with
this dark tone that they're going with
the series the bar that they end up
hanging out a lot at is Josie's that's
also straight out of the daredevil
comics the classic daredevil comics
really I think like the biggest WTF from
these two episodes is the end of episode
4 when kingpin
like literally decapitate the Russian
with the car door I mean he beats the
crap out of him first but he literally
just keeps smashing that door that's a
good example of how daredevil is like an
HBO version of a Marvel TV show like an
HBO version of agents of shield we also
get a teaser for another comic book
character Melvin Potter he's the guy
that makes kingpins special armored
suits they only reference him in the
comics he eventually turns into the
gladiator character I'm not really
expecting that on the daredevil show we
really only just got like a slight
introduction to him I'll talk about him
more in my later videos because he's
definitely important to the Matt Murdock
daredevil character just to go a little
bit deeper into some of the characters
that I haven't talked about a lot leland
owlsley he is a big villain from the
daredevil comics and in his own right
beyond kingpin he's appeared in the more
recent daredevil comics - like a younger
version of him but his character traits
flow a lot from what you see on screen
like he's a money man calculating but
very dangerous like a version of kingpin
if he was much more analytical and
calculating basically an accountant
which is what he's playing on the TV
series it's just an added bonus that the
villain from Shawshank is playing him I
know a lot of people are wondering if
the Claire Temple character is tied to
Luke Cage because in the comics they
used to be married I mean they're
they're divorced Claire said that she
had an ex that was named Mike that could
be Mike Peterson from agents of shield
aka Deathlok I kind of think it's more
of a coincidence because they have a
child together Deathlok and his wife
based on the age of that child Claire
would have had to have the baby when she
was really really young so it is I mean
it's possible but I think it's more of a
coincidence if you're one
how old the characters are on this think
about it this way so Matt and foggy just
ended their internship right after law
school so they're still in their late
20s
I think Claire's about the same age no
idea how old Luke Cage jessica jones or
iron fist are gonna be whenever they
show up these seasons these first
seasons are pseudo origin stories so I'd
expect them to be younger to like late
20s early 30s tops the Ben Urich
character also from the comics he's just
a big reporter that comments a lot on
like big storylines he's like this moral
voice like like the voice of God or the
voice of the narrator just commenting on
like stuff like civil war with the
heroes fighting each other it's like the
writers of the the comic book storylines
that he appears in use him to comment on
their stories it's like the way agent
Carter used those Captain America radio
broadcasts it's the same type of thing
in the TV series he's more of a real
character but usually like in the comic
books when he appears it's more of like
this Captain America radio play
commentary stuff I know everyone's kind
of pissed that he works for the Daily
Bulletin and not the Daily Bugle but I
think when they were writing this they
hadn't reached an agreement with Sony so
they they just had to stay away from
spider-man stuff they did do an age of
Ultron press conference where Kevin
Feige confirmed that spider-man would be
Peter Parker in Captain America Civil
War and he would be in high school but
that's all they said they didn't say how
much he would appear in civil war only
that he'd be in it somewhere I suspect
that they probably have a pretty good
idea who their actor is and they're just
waiting for them to sign a contract so
expect them to announce who that
spider-man is sometime after age of
Ultron comes out in theaters so what I'm
gonna do is I'm going to post my next
daredevil video sometime probably like
Tuesday because Game of Thrones is
tomorrow so like all of Sunday and part
of Monday will be dedicated to Game of
Thrones there's a new ant-man trailer
that's gonna post on Monday so be sure
to subscribe to get everything it's
gonna be a great couple of days just the
case you're not caught up on Game of
Thrones you can click here for like my
season 1 to season 4 catch-up video and
you can click here for all my other
daredevil Avengers videos I just posted
like a fun age of Ultron behind the
scenes video thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tomorrow
you